quant à la radio
par lou reed entamera mérigots
[Musique]
on pas grillades et commence à couvin
d'élodée face à
si bien tatiana cac 40
[Musique]
à laâyoune la marina
en normandie on s'habille à goes ebay
quant à east haddam saône qui me raison
on élit bosso views kuroda les gones
à son tour la paramécie me tient quant à
nos gammes et non non non non non c'est
un chalet
monsieur françois padovani vous êtes un
chantre de la châtaigne et des moulins
du vieux moulin être apparemment ici
nous sommes dans un séchoir de
châtaignes qui est sans doute plusieurs
fois séculaire oui de mémoire de vieux
il a toujours existé d'ailleurs la
maison est très ancienne on a toujours
ses chais des châtaignes mais où le bois
est très très vieux
ce sont des ridelles en bois de
châtaignier passe pour la bonne
bon séchage des châtaignes et à propos
de moulins de moulins chapelles
vous avez opté pour le système anti
système hydraulique plutôt que le
système à macao système électrique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi mais c'est bien simple il ya
d'abord un côté sentimental parce que là
où j'ai remonté le moulin est toujours
un moulin mon père qui a 84 ans ça
rappelle très bien on l'appelait le
moulin dit quoi traîné et il y avait
d'ailleurs à cet endroit
8 moulin sur les chevaliers sur 200 m on
l'appelle les moulins le lieu s'appelle
les moulins et puis en dehors de ce côté
sentimental
on a toujours dit n'est ce pas et des
choix que c'est vrai que l'ong curiosité
et le parfum le bouquet de la farine
moulue d'un jean moulin hydraulique n'a
jamais pu être égalé par d'autres
procédés est ce qu'on peut apporter une
amorce un semblant d'explication
outre que sentimentale bas il est
évident qu'il ya un système de
refroidissement qui se faire
naturellement puisque
une turbine bas n'est ce pas qui est
souhaité par l'eau en dessous de
lamelles intérieure de corse m il fixe
de qui donc refroidi automatiquement un
peu comme radiateur de voitures qui est
un circuit d'eau mais finalement c'est
un rythme naturel des hitman naturel en
somme c'est naturel et je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut surtout recherché
combien de temps on peut comprendre à
mon avis une sorte de retour aux sources
bien entendu mais la maintenance
l'entretien de cette mule nécessite
certainement des tours de main
particuliers belges il ya d'abord le
brossage quotidien des mains n'est ce
pas chaque matin avant d'entamer le
travail avant de commencer une journée
on commence par démonter le moulin de
soulever lamelles supérieur n'est ce pas
est brossé les dents les mains de façon
à ce que à sortir des appareils qui
restent et la veille et qui risque de
devenir pâteuse et de faire évidemment
patiner
cette année à la farine qui va se faire
selon curiosité et puis il ya également
tout laissé tous les jours il ya ce
qu'on appelle le rhabillage des moeurs
n'est ce pas il y avait plutôt spéciaux
et des écoutes au nom des marteaux
spéciaux qui permettent un espace ce
travail est un travail qui est un
scandale hier est très très délicat
alors on parle de couteau justement de
peignes de quoi s'agit-il bien dans une
meule il y a les couteaux ce sont des
des formes n'est ce pas d'être est
profond et qui sont d'ailleurs faits par
le tailleur de pierre et puis lien
également les dents des dents elles
partent assez paix c est une liste très
fine de façon ce sont les dernières
ensemble qui kivu produisent 7 sera
finale de la prime les premières et en
un destiné à envoyer des châtaignes et
les transmettre au fur et à mesure est
ce que vous sentez qu'il ya un retour ne
pas vers la farine de châtaigne est ce
que et il y à une demande accrue de ce
produit moi je pense qu'on peut dire ce
qu'il faut surtout c'est s'appliquer à
faire de très bonnes par ina et je crois
qu'il n'y a pas de problème pour la
vente et elle est très demandée parce
que les gens veulent de plus en plus de
produits naturels
ce serait votre sens un débouchés
assurés pour ceux qui envisagerait
d'aller dans la même voie que la vôtre
n'est ce pas mais pourquoi pas oui ma
choix qu'il ya de la place pour tout le
monde et je pense qu'il ya
d'affaires réalisé
[Musique]